what we're going to go over in this
video is one of the core principles in
calculus we're going to use it anytime
you take the derivative of anything even
reasonably complex and it's called the
chain rule and when you're first exposed
to it it can seem a little daunting and
a little bit convoluted but as you see
more and more examples it'll start to
make sense and hopefully you'll even
start to seem a little bit simple and
intuitive over time so let's say that I
had a function let's say I have a
function H of X and it is equal to just
for example I let's say it's equal to
sine of X let's say it's equal to sine
of x squared now I could have written
that I could have written it like this
sine squared of X but it'll be a little
bit clearer using using that type of
notation so let me make it so I have H
of X and what I'm curious about is what
is H prime of X so I want to know H
prime of X which another way of writing
it is there was the derivative of H with
respect to X these are just different
notations and to do this I'm going to
use the chain rule I am going to use the
chain rule and the chain rule comes into
play every time any time your function
can be used as a composition of more
than one function and as that might not
seem obvious right now but it will
hopefully maybe by the end of this video
or the next one now what I want to do is
a little bit of a thought experiment a
little bit of a thought experiment if I
were to ask you what is the derivative
with respect to X if I were just apply
the derivative operator to x squared
with respect to X what do I get
well this gives me 2x we've seen that
many many many many times now what if I
were to take the derivative with respect
to a of a squared what's the exact same
thing I just swapped an A for the X's
this is still going to be equal to 2ei
now I will do something that might be a
little bit more bizarre what if I were
to take the derivative with respect to
sine of X with respect to sine of X of
of sine of X sine of x squared well
wherever I had the X's up here the A's
over here I just replace it with a sine
of X so this is just going to be 2 times
with the thing that I had so whatever
I'm taking the derivative with respect
to here was with respect to X
here's respect to a here's with respect
to sine of X so it's going to be 2 times
sine of X now so the chain rule tells us
that this derivative is going to be the
derivative of our whole function with
respect or the derivative of this outer
function x squared the derivative of x
squared the derivative of this outer
function with respect to sine of X so
that's going to be 2 sine of X 2 sine of
X so we could view it as the derivative
of the outer function with respect to
the inner - sine of X we could just
treat sine of X like it's kind of an X
and it would have been just 2x but
instead it's a sine of X we say 2 sine
of X x times the derivative just in
green times the derivative of sine of X
with respect to x times the derivative
of sine of X with respect to X well
that's more straightforward a little bit
more intuitive the derivative of sine of
X with respect to X we've seen multiple
times is cosine of X so times cosine of
X and so there we've applied the chain
rule it was the derivative of the outer
function with respect to the inner so
derivative of sine of x squared with
respect to sine of X is 2 sine of X and
then we multiply that times the
derivative of sine of X with respect to
X so let me make it clear this right
over here is the derivative we're taking
the derivative of we're taking the
derivative of sine of x squared so let
me make it clear that's what we're
taking the derivative of with respect to
sine of X with respect to sine of X and
then we're multiplying that times the
derivative of sine of X the derivative
of sine of X with respect to with
respect to X and this is where it start
might start making a little bit of
intuition you can't really treat these
differentials this D whatever this DX
this D sine of X as as a as a as a
number and you really can't there's a
notation makes it look like a fraction
because intuitively that's what we're
doing but if you were to treat them like
fractions then you could think about
canceling
that and that and once again this isn't
a rigorous thing to do but it can help
with the intuition and then what you're
left with is the derivative of this
whole sine of x squared with respect to
X so you're left with you're left with
the derivative of essentially our
original function sine of x squared with
respect to X with respect to X which is
exactly what dhdx is this right over
here this right over here is our
original function H that's our original
function H so it might seem a little bit
daunting now what I'll do in the next
video is another several examples and
then we'll try to abstract that this a
little bit